we have an update for you this morning  about NBA star drew holiday and his  family after a tough year they  celebrated their adorable daughter's  first birthday yesterday we reported  last year that holidays wife Lauren was  diagnosed with a brain tumor and retired  from professional soccer drew took a  leave of absence from the NBA to care  for his family he posted a photo of his  one-year-old Instagram yesterday and  wrote one year later my love and world  are healthy and happy and we are glad to  report Lauren's health continues to  improve goose but moment nothing more  important than that as we know will be  healthy yes family love Jake